l'insertion professionnelle des
réunionnais fait partie des principales
missions du département
en 2014 la collectivité à financer les
allocations de solidarité à hauteur de
38 5 millions d'euros pour mener une
politique efficace et cohérente
le département mise sur l'insertion des
publics en difficulté tout en agissant
sur l'économie dans les domaines du
service à la personne ou du tourisme
mais aussi à travers le challenge des
créateurs l'insertion par l'économie est
favorisée à l'antre-2 daisy s'occupe de
sa maman atteinte d'alzheimer depuis
deux ans une aide à plein temps facilité
par le versement de la paix a comme je
ne savais pas quoi faire quand j'ai
écrit au conseil général lui demander de
me conseiller et ils m'ont fait un
dossier en disant voilà je pouvais aider
prendre ma meilleure et percevoir un
petit peu d'appétit pour m'occuper
d'elle je pense que oui un jour je
pourrai l'homme est renvoyé mais ce
serait vraiment la fin parce que bien
sûr magnin ensuite ali en tant qu on n a
fait qu il voit pas elle est juste à
côté cet argent n'est pas loin pour
arriver noir en matière de tourisme
la filière bois de goyavier est un
exemple d'insertion par l'économie en
plein développement
elle a tous les atouts nécessaires pour
séduire les touristes venus se mettre au
vert dans les jardins du vvf à
l'ermitage les agents installe en ce
moment des cabanes perchées réalisé à
partir de bois pays
une première qui répond à une véritable
demande
oui la demande elle est là les gens qui
passent ils peuvent pas s'empêcher de
tourner la tête et de venir poser des
questions et de demander quel prix
combien ça coûte une cabane comme ça et
je veux dire un prix comme ça
entre un millier à 5000 euros et une
cabane perchée ou une cabane pmr à 50000
dos 50 mètres carrés enfin à travers le
challenge des créateurs un coup de pouce
est apportée aux personnes en recherche
d'emploi qui ont créé leur entreprise
marie danielle mercat à la tête des
éditions la plume et le parchemin est
une des lauréates 2014 une période de
chômage pendant laquelle j'ai été auteur
en fait j'ai écrit plusieurs courriers
et j'ai rencontré votre hauteur dans le
même cas
et du coup ben je vois voulu et créé ce
projet là et puis créer mon propre
emploi aussi alors le challenge des
créateurs n'a apporté une reconnaissance
énorme
donc voilà le cri de l'assertion format
c'est si le plus beau à serait tout ce
combat que j'ai mené avant j'étais
toujours à courir derrière tout le monde
est là maintenant on m'appelle pour me
dire revient faire des ateliers des
condensés été terrassé moment énorme
voilà ça va plus loin j'espère permettre
de développer tout ce que tout ce que je
fais professionnaliser les publics en
recherche d'emploi agir sur l'économie
et développer des filières d'avenir tels
sont les objectifs poursuivis par le
département grâce à l'insertion par
l'économie